[Music]
right listen up i've got four letters to
describe this next dish o m f g
that could mean only one thing a
delicious steak sandwich packed with
flavor
two slices of bread and trust me this
dish will not make you the idiot
sandwich in your household right oscar
pan down
please
babette steak or anglet as they say on
false
the chef's cut
and it is super delicious really cheap
it is the perfect steak
for a sandwich beautiful big flat cap
mushrooms onions a beautiful coltan
battered blue cheese lettuce and a
little bit of peppery watercress mustard
tabasco lean pearing mustard and
a beautiful loaf of bread
right let's have 10 minutes on the clock
please
now first thing
you want to slice this
big
slipper
into half okay
now
i like using the chapata
bread i like to sort of douse it in some
extra virgin olive oil i like to season
it
nicely inside but watch
salt pepper
generously okay
a touch of chili flake on there
generously
and then look
get that on the grill okay
now
get something heavy
a plate on there and just
push that down
that's going to get you
a really nice crisp
beautiful
amazing color on there
now
the steak
usually season it okay really important
because sometimes you think there's a
lot of salt to the naked eye but it's
not because we lose 30 of it the minute
it hits the grill
get that out of the fridge at least
three or four minutes before you're
going to cook it
it's got very little fat but it is quite
fibrous okay so you need to be super
careful of not overcooking it the secret
of a good steak like that is letting it
rest okay let's just check our bread
i want a really nice color on there
and open that up that's what i want
and those chilies are doing their magic
push it down okay the bread will bounce
back up but get those marks on that
bread it will make a huge difference
now
off
goes one okay beautiful
off goes the second one now we go on
with our steak okay
let's get the hottest part on
again roll it around that marinade and
get it on there so bread's working
steak is cooking don't keep on flipping
the steak leave it on there okay
now let's start thinking about the
garnish
i love these big flat cap mushrooms i
love them take off the stalks
mush them on okay
they'll break down
they'll start cooking literally
in seconds
a nice
season on those mushrooms okay
think of the way we're laying this up
okay i've got my steak i've got my
mushrooms onions
this time
go about a centimeter
thick
and start slicing some beautiful onion
rings but don't worry about opening them
up just get them on there
okay
and start
grill them hold like that
they'll break up
but
again
from there a little touch
of seasoning okay
now
i want to talk to you about the
sort of
the sauce how do we come together with
this flavor i've got some mustard
tabasco and liam perry it's a wonderful
combination
turn that steak over look at that color
it's exactly what we want
beautifully done mushrooms
turn them over
and then when it comes to the onions a
little bit smaller a little bit fiddlier
doesn't matter
on there
and on and you can see those colors now
from there
take your worcester sauce
a couple of tablespoons in there first
your tabasco
first
off painted brush
and just start
glazing that steak okay
as we start
to cook
the flavor and the smell in here is
incredible
it's almost like a little varnish okay
over the onions as well
now all that flavor from the steak is
coming out it's running into the
mushrooms it's running into the onions
and it is absolutely delicious
now from there
take
two nice teaspoons
of
mayonnaise
in
two nice teaspoons of mayonnaise
one nice teaspoon
of dijon mustard generously done
a tablespoon of lemon perrin
and give that a really nice mix
this is our lining for the bread okay
little taste
a touch of spice a little bit more with
the tabasco
i like it quite sort of
hot so that's incredibly
rich for the steak
salt pepper
and
that's gonna be my dipping sauce okay
dipping sauce and sauce is gonna be on
top of that bread
time please
halfway
now
sauce goes in
okay
look at that beautifully done the secret
behind making a great steak sandwich is
getting organized
and this is how i get organized i dress
everything first
so first off
one
spoon all the way down
okay
start laying this beauty up now
from there
open up my lettuce
snap the lettuce and slice that in half
okay
snap it
and slice it in half and then gonna dust
that
with my peppery watercress
okay
and then from there lightly season that
in there really important salt and
pepper
and then look get your dipping sauce
and just
throw that over okay now think of the
layers we've got
okay
so beautiful let that sit
it's all in the build-up and if you can
build and cook at the same time even
better now look
the mushrooms
are coming down beautifully the onions
are caramelized
so once that steak is cooked okay
there's a nice surprise to this
and think of the combination
guinness mistakes like tomato and basil
just flood that grill with a touch of
guinness
and just let that guinness literally
absorb
through those mushrooms
through those onions
and through that steak
and look
what i'm gonna do now
is roll that steak
over that guinness
and that caramelizes beautifully and the
flavor of that
is just incredible
now look
the guinness evaporates
the alcohol is burnt off but the flavor
is incredible
off with the gas just leave that sitting
there okay
now
we're gonna start
building this up
i take my onions
off the grill
and i dot them
over that beautiful salad
the secret behind any great steak
sandwich is in the build
okay
look at that
my mushrooms
come off and they sit on top the smell
of that guinness
it's beautiful
and then there
now for the steak time please
two minutes now for the steak look at
that
i'm going to slice this
on the bias
down
not too thin
not too thick
and look
color
there once that's sliced
lift that up
and then sit that on top
and get that on there
i'm happy for it to sort of bleed and
those juices to run through that steak
sandwich next one off again on a bias
again
that guinness
is delicious
the flavor
is
unreal
sit that on top
be generous with that okay you can't
stick a whole steak in there slice it
and let it go
now before we close that over
season it lightly touch the salt
touch the pepper
and then your dipping sauce
one more time
over she goes
beginning smells delicious
and then finally
turn that round
look at that
and finally it's beautiful
age still and sit that on if you can get
that on whilst the steak is nice and hot
it helps melt the cheese
but sort of hide it
okay a little bit sort of mischief with
it stick it underneath stick it on the
side
and just sort of sit it crumble it on
top of that hot stake
and that's going to lift that
to another level and then
say goodbye
because you stick that on top of there
you get your knife
you slice that bad boy
and trust me
you open that up
take a bite
and you're ready to die
and there you go a delicious steak and
guinness
sandwich
to all of you thank you for watching
ramsay intend if i went too quick i
apologize but slow it down now don't
forget to pick up ramsey intent cookbook
inspired by this series and trust me
you're going to come out a much better
chef and if you like this video don't
forget to subscribe to my amazing
youtube channel for more good luck